on the hill tonight for the indians
aaron savali trying to become major
league baseball's
first 10-game winner so aaron savali
to face cedric mullins the left-handed
hitting center fielder
one of baseball's best hitters in the
month of june and he laces ahead on the
third pitch of the game
he'll turn for two and that's double
number 18
for cedric mullins you know you keep
talking about this is an all-star
performer well look at this i mean he
goes down and gets that curveball
this one may be in doesn't break quite
as much leadoff man in scoring position
now for trey mancini
mancini racks one into left field that
will
fall in front of rosario a late break
for mullins who gets to third
and a well-placed ball from trey puts
runners on the corners
nobody out just five pitches into the
night so here's freddie galvez a switch
hitter he'll band left-handed
and galva is a first pitch on and a base
hit into right field
mancini's gonna go first to third cedric
mullins is in freddie galvez
with the first pitch assault it's three
hits in
six pitches in a one-nothing lead mount
castle against indians pitching this
year
batting 438 with a couple of home runs
now castle off the end of the bat center
field bradley zimmer's not going to get
there
it's four hits in a row for the orioles
trey is in
galvez to second mount castle does in
savanni again and they're off to the
races in cleveland
aaron sivali is a ground ball from
getting out of the inning well he would
love that wouldn't he get a ground ball
austin hayes hitting on 99 career hits
did it
there's one and two
inning over orioles get a pair
so keegan aiken there's your runs you
got two of them make them
use them wisely here's jose ramirez
batting 340 over the last 12 games
smack the deep left field and that is
gone
it stayed up and cleared the wall and
jose ramirez with home run number 15
gets a run right back for cleveland did
it go through the railing or did it just
clear the rails i think it went through
them
i don't think it went over it because
that was just a line shot
[Applause]
let's see let's see let's see it looks
like it went didn't it go did it go
right through
it looked like it trey mancini going to
lead off inning number three baltimore
on top 2-1
and trey gets a hold of this one into
the corner a fair ball
want to hop to the fence and mancini's
going to book it for second
he is in there as the throw gets away
hit it so hard there was a possible play
at second base
but it is a rip shot of a double for
trey his 15.
castle is 6'4 230. former first round
pick
little flare single to center his first
time drove in a run
and a breaking ball here that smoked
into left field that is down for a hit
that's going to score trey mancini mount
castle will hold it first
back to back rbi singles for ryan mout
castle
there's your curveball again so double
the mullins on a hook
and just let me tell you about hanging
curve balls on the inside part of the
plate to righties
get the same result hooks it down into
the corner i thought there's actually
going to be a double
because ryan can run a little bit now
for the second time in as many innings a
hit in a walk
and the indians have two men aboard
the 1-2 is lined into left-field basin
here comes bradley zimmer
zooming around third no chance to get
him he'll score easily
the throw went through what is cesar
hernandez doing
finally he picks up the ball and gets to
third base
he was frozen like a statue out there he
took his eye off
when the ball was all the way to the
backstop hernandez with his head down he
never picked up the baseball he wasn't
paying attention zimmer's gonna score
because he can run
they're going to challenge with stuart
czar throw
off line he stewart had his head down
and you can see
there's sarbaugh just saying let's go
where are you going watch him he put his
head down
he's not looking at it looks like he's
looking at it but i don't know what he
saw
now jose shoots it in the right field
fernandez scores the tying run
here comes the med rosario with the go
ahead run jose drawing the
throw he's in a run down and he's going
to be
safe how do you like them apples and now
he's going to go to third
incredible
second he was short of second
ramirez went to second then saw nobody
was at third
and he kept going to third and beat
everybody there
indians with a 4-3 lead nobody out
the infield is drawn in cut of the grass
around the horn
and a base hit left field all the way
down into the corner by
big harold posey scores
harold in the second and the indians are
swinging big time here at inning number
three
so the indians have now taken a 5-3 lead
a runner at second nobody out here's
eddie rosario
oh rosario just yanks it down the right
field line all the way to the wall
he's got two in comes big herald a
five-run
inning for cleveland and they're still
not done because there's
nobody out two down runners still at
first
ryan mount castle will step in
he hits a fly ball to deep left field
this thing's gonna go
ryan mount castle does in aaron sivali
once again his second home run
in as many games against savali and the
orioles are within a run
zimmer got a base hit he's rolling it
over to the top of the lineup to
cesar hernandez to see if the indians
can maybe add on here with two outs
that's hugging the line it's a fair ball
around third scoring is ramirez
coming around third zimmer i mean he's
like a gazelle
he's gonna score without a throw
cesar hernandez delivering with the two
out
two run triple yeah and you'll see it
goes right over the bag
my goodness it shaved the edge couldn't
have been placed any better
and how about that i mean with two outs
a walk
a hit and then a clutch hit it
[Applause]
and now the orioles runners at the
corners down three with one out
austin hayes into right field to base
hit hayes
rbi single for austin picks up that
first hit off the injured list
and keeps the train rolling in the
seventh tang runs the board
go ahead run at the plate
bronco at the pinch hit rbi single
against shaw the other night he smokes
this one into center
stewart is going to go around third the
throw is tipped
and the cut off in the middle of the
field allows dj
stewart to come in a two-run inning for
the orioles
the runners behind him hayes and franco
go to third and second respectively
and it's eight to seven annual clause a
with a chance
at his 11th save of the year as era is
under one
two pitch to hayes
bouncer to third ramirez long throw
book it
the indians have won three in a row over
the birds they've won nine of their last
13.